uh
excuse me you're you're my speed am i
actually yes you are you're one of those
weirdo compulsives who come to the same
restaurants
the same chair and eat the same food
every day
uh no no no i was sitting right there
three minutes ago and then i went
outside to get
myself a paper i ordered a juice and
look i made a crawling snake with a
straw wrapper you can finish it if you
think you're up to the job
i'm sorry you want me to move not
anymore
so what's up i don't have time to talk
but you haven't heard what i'm going to
say
see now we've already talked more than i
wanted to
[Music]
oh i did give you my seat you know i
think that gets me one question
listen diner guy sean sean flattered
really
very often i am happy to meet new people
but today right here right now i can't
talk
i understand i do what if i do the
talking for both of us
have at it do you mind if i read the
paper and stare aimlessly out the window
while you two talk
no can i get a name to work with
julia well it's very nice to meet you
juliet
it's nice to meet you too sean and i'm
sorry about your seat
so lunch is on me so what do you do for
a living i do a little bit of everything
oh that sounds interesting and maybe a
little bit dangerous oh i like your
jacket i like it i don't like it can i
stop you there first off in uh your
portrayal of me
i sound like i'm in the eighth grade
well my portrayal of you you only have
an eighth grade education
all right uh smarten you up uh college
yeah top your class graduate early
got it i'm new to town and i don't know
many people
but i do know my cats two of them
the gray one is very affectionate the
white one makes me work much
much harder for the attention and what
about your family
my family is amazing my parents have
been together for what is it 30 years
now
okay do we know each other yes you were
the girl who stole my seat
oh my gosh you're a cop not a cop
the paper the vantage point the layout
of course you've got
defensive and scary guy walked in you're
totally a
cop okay sean i'm gonna need you to do
me a favor
duck
oh hey jules what are you doing here i'm
returning my equipment what are you
doing here
i'm just hanging you know chilling
it's actually feeling a little nostalgic
remember when we cracked that case here
and the criminals turned out to be
roller derby girls
yeah i remember that gosh seems like it
was
just yesterday probably because it was
yesterday why are you wearing skates
oh yeah look at that yes i am i don't
know
uh i guess i just thought it was a shame
we have this big beautiful track and no
one to skate on it
it's also been a long while since i've
had a good blister hmm
this will be a couple skate couples only
[Music]
come on
[Music]
did you do that on purpose no
maybe okay yes
yes i did
[Music]
jules what are you doing here what i
mean is you know who who's gonna fit mr
yang with her straight jacket and
iron mask with face grill something
tells me there's an entire precinct of
officers bidding on that job right now
uh can i interest you in a uh a necco
wafer
sean can you just not talk for a few
seconds look
i just wanted to tell you that what you
did today
i mean i can't imagine being able to
function at that level while your mom
was
you know i am uh
clearly not as good with words as you
are
and um i know that
things between us have been a little
complicated
and that there have probably been some
mixed signals mostly
for me with regards to the time that we
spend
together outside of the line of duty
look jules
just please just let me finish stumbling
through this i'm almost done i promise
what i'm saying is that i think
maybe the best things the richest
things aren't supposed to come easily
and that sometimes the moments that make
the most sense happen when
everything else doesn't and well
i think you deserve more than popcorn
tonight
[Music]
so why don't you let me take you to
dinner
detective o'hara are you asking me out
on a date i
am a proper one
wow i cannot believe this
all this time and your timing is just
awful it is yeah it's just
dreadful what i can't go to dinner with
you
jules i'm already on a date you are what
here
yeah right now it's weird it's a little
weird but uh
yeah with abigail the one that got away
[Music]
[Music]
get out there
she's not gonna wait forever
have an amazing trip
okay promise me
because you know they say that uh these
these kind of trips are
once-in-a-lifetime experiences and that
they're even better
when you have someone you care about to
share them with and
you do
take lots of pictures not of sights
don't take
pictures of buildings take pictures of
moments
cause that's what matters capture them
here
and hold on to them here
at least that's what i would do i don't
know you might take blurry photos of
your espresso at some random cafe
[Music]
hey buddy buddy hey
uh i'm not gonna have to worry any more
about that uh hotel and amalfi being all
booked up
oh yeah why is that because i just
bought it
oh yeah
well good luck with that man gus and i
ever make it out that way we'll uh look
forward to stealing some towels
can we not do this right now it's okay
the way things are it's okay
i just really need to sort this out on
my own right now
can i just say what i what i came here
to say please
i have a motorcycle yes
you do yes i do you know what it is
it is the purest form of freedom that i
have ever experienced
you zip through traffic you park
anywhere you never have to take anyone
to the airport
you certainly don't have to help anyone
move easily the best purchase i've ever
made
in my life and i have never regretted it
not for one second
great you love your motorcycle
is there a point to this yeah there's a
point the point is
since i met you i
i've been thinking about getting a car
and you're not thinking something
practical or
sensible throwing in the towel together
[Music]
you and me tonight
this is awesome
first question what is your name
there is a murderer on the list that is
not your name
sean spencer
truth we're off to a good start where
were you
the night of the party let's see uh
let's talk with gus
[Music]
played some video games
[Music]
yeah we were talking a little star wars
[Music]
look lassie we both know what this is
about this about me and julia
answer only my questions please yes
we're together you hate it i get it
spencer i
i can't help it man i've been fighting
this thing for years spencer's just
gonna go away stop she's gonna have to
deal with the fact that i love her okay
hmm lasseter said
you had a vision of herb with michael
damien
but you had this receipt
so you knew herb would be there
[Music]
right
maybe the best things the richest
things aren't supposed to come easily
and that sometimes the moments that make
the most sense happen when
everything else doesn't
sean are you listening to me
falling in love with you was never part
of the plan okay
this whole thing started because my ass
was on the line
self-preservation jules you gotta
understand that i didn't have a choice
and then we sort of found a groove
and by the time you showed up it was so
much fun
we put away like over a hundred
criminals
most of them are murderers
i'm good at what i do
and what i do
it's good
isn't it what
are you talking about
are you telling me this is all a lie
please don't make me answer that oh my
god
oh my god i feel so stupid no sweetheart
now this
this is all me
this is
me call you back
dude i've got huge news jules and i
are back together again officially she
made me work for it but i came all the
way back
she couldn't resist this forever i hear
that i got good news too
i think i got my face back check it out
what am i looking at i'm seeing
whimsical
with a touch of constipation this is
gonna be so incredible
just like it was before only bigger and
better with more wineries
except for one thing what you
i made the biggest mistake in my life by
leaving santa barbara without saying
goodbye to goss and i am done
cowering from the big decisions i've
wanted this
for long enough
so what's gonna happen
right now sean
is is this the time
bet your asses juliet o'hara
i do not believe in love at first sight
because i didn't even need to see you to
know that i wanted to spin forever with
you
that didn't make it sound a sense that
it the center of the universe
nine planets gus has that pluto line
ever worked on anybody
no i'm gonna get back in there
scratch that i have spent my whole life
running from one thing to another
quitting and running and quitting and
running and pretending that my destiny
was to drive a wiener moment
he was young and afraid of commitment
that's true but i'm not that young
anymore
and i'm also not afraid because when i'm
with you jules
i'm just fearless and and i'm
unbreakable
like samuel l jackson
now sam jackson was the glass man not
emotionally shot
not emotionally okay i need you to dial
it back just
just a tiny bit oh okay
i know that i come with baggage and a
best friend who's not going anywhere
ever
but i promise you that from this moment
forward the only running that i will be
doing is into your arms and i will never
stop holding
your cold little hands or losing myself
when i wake up in the morning and look
at you
and recognize how freaking lucky i am oh
my gosh
oh my gosh it's happening say yes yes
okay but technically you just said yes
to gus well ask me sean
will you marry us me mostly me even
though
gus is always going to be part of the
deal and that someday he'll have his own
juliet
and her name will be julie and she'll be
jamaican
and together we'll be one big giant
frosted black and white cookie
and we're gonna have dogs all rescues
and kids
probably before we're 16. oh wait wait
before 16. oh just marry me so that i
can show you how amazing our life will
be together yes
yes i will marry the crap out of you
sean spencer now give me the ring
oh my god hey hey that's my
grandfather's oh my god what the hell
kind of city is this though
come on let's do this and why is the
window broken
it's technically stolen hold on
right you went left let go of the wheel
you let go
i have the gas do not make me slam the
[Applause]
brakes
we close our eyes